good morning everyone happy Friday
finally we made it today we have such a
fun episode of the morning toast because
I am here with the skinny confidential
foreign efforts Bostick can you for
having me thank you for being here we
have so many questions for you and I
have so many personal questions for you
we've just been sitting here for the
past 20 minutes like ruining the show
because I couldn't hold my questions in
about how to get better Instagram flow
but we will get into all of that in a
bit
we are per usual going to hit you with
the fast 5 stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast but first let's
just catch up with you welcome to New
York
thank you how has it been it's been
amazing I am eating a little bit too
much pasta I understand I feel a little
bloated anywhere good Carbone ok we also
went to Campagnolo last night it's on
the Upper East Side it's like very like
you feel like you're in the 50s there's
a piano martini but I'm just feeling so
bloated from the pasta I need to walk
more what like what is your skinny
confidential tip for when you feel
bloated I've been doing intermittent
fasting Lynne here so I will just not
eat for 16 hours and I'm actually
experimenting with it and trying it and
I like it so far so I just wake up I do
coffee I have like a fiber power doors
that I put in it and then I do water
with lemon and tea and then I'll eat at
like 12 o'clock and I'll eat normal
because I have to enjoy the pasta and
the bread so totally it's all about
balance it's all about balance so what
brings you to New York just work work
work play also my parents have never
been to New York they're here here my
dad usually love them and they they've
never been so we wanted to take them and
Michael's parents are here with us so we
kind of did like a family thing and
we're just enjoying the city and eating
our way through it well welcome we're so
happy to have you and I'm so excited for
this episode I know we're going to talk
about Instagram feeds we're gonna talk
about Instagram feeds we're gonna talk
about skincare Beauty wellness all the
things that you are an expert on and
I've like been more and more taking care
of like myself with like vitamins and
whatnot I don't know that it's really
working but vitamins you got a facial
massage yeah I mean cut back on the
pasta for me yeah drink a lot of water
water I like
right electro cinnamon in the coffee oh
really always what about the blood sugar
and I drink hazelnut coffee so will
taste really good so good okay and I
carried my purse like a little vial of
cinnamon only I would look like as
though through your purse not right now
none of us weekly articles that are like
what's in my purse they need to profile
you because I feel like there's so much
we could learn crumble Gigi Crocker's
lip venom lip gloss like that's open
splattered everywhere a vial of cinnamon
and in this bleak that's amazing
okay so before we get into all of that
we are gonna hit you with the stories
that you need to know this morning
weirdly a lot happened last night sort
of so we are here to inform you about it
first up Drake confirms that he has a
son on the new album Scorpio quote the
kid is mine so I'm sure you've heard
about all this drama between Tariq and I
believe it was a push a tee I haven't
okay so they were like having a rap
battle as they as one does and then
pushes he likes throughout their that
Drake has a child like that he had with
a random girl a year ago do we know who
she is
I'm not sure that it's confess she's a
French former adult film star Sophie
Brousseau
ooh scandalous scandalous so I think the
child's about a year old now and he was
hiding the kid from the world and then
like Pusha T brought it out into the
open he probably is doing this for us
though don't you think like he's hiding
he's like holding back perhaps yeah like
this is a perfect time to announce it
and he confirmed it on his new song so I
wonder what this means like if we're
gonna ever meet the child what do you
think the child's name is did they
release the name I don't know but the
child is only like 1 or 2 so it hasn't
been that long it's a child on Instagram
yeah and no and that's the real shame
yeah you sure the child would have a
wife a child aesthetic
you call it ascetic I call it flow
because my little sister Margot like
calls it flow I'm gonna start calling it
flow it like whoa right yeah I'm over
aesthetic it's it's too bougie yeah
that's true and flow is just like it
makes it feel less like premeditated oh
yeah okay that's my new word I start
using it like don't know go for it thank
Martha thanks snitch for keeping us
young anyways the article reads from
Peppa
calm Drake just dropped a bombshell he's
a daddy the 31 year old rapper confirmed
the long rumor news that he fathered a
child with French former adult film star
Sophie Brousseau on his new double album
Scorpio which was released just before
midnight Thursday on Apple music and his
track emotionless which samples Mariah
Carey Drake declares quote I wasn't
hiding my kid from the world
I was hiding the world from my kid very
fair this is a scary world we live in
little Kylie Jenner II yes little Kylie
Jenner I sure he took a page out of her
playbook he says breaking news in my
life I don't run to the blogs the ones I
the only ones I want to tell are the
ones I can call that's fair she's not my
lover like Billie Jean but the kid is
mine
damn I feel the next albums gonna be all
about her or him her I don't know I feel
like oh it was like that there's a child
I think it might be his son because I
feel like I would yes his son's mother
okay cuz I would remember if it was like
if he had a baby girl I feel like he'll
be a really good dad actually he will be
a good assuming like he you know now on
top to the fact that he's a bad yeah
good for drink good for trade
I still like want him to find true love
but I feel like that time is not gonna
come for a while really I think we're
waiting on that that's gonna be all do
you think it what kind of girl do you
think I think he was gonna have to go
through like a Kris Humphries situation
like Kim did to get to his Kanye you
know yeah you feel that for him I do but
do you feel like him and Rihanna are
ever gonna be together
I see Briana might be his Kanye that's
true but like I feel like he would marry
Rihanna tomorrow but like she would not
marry him
gab that's always how it goes though
like Kanye like was chasing Kim you know
that's true Michael was like that with
me you got to make him wait for like
years and years and years and let him
get really obsessed with you it's sad
what happened between the two yeah like
I made him wait and wait and wait and
wait it was like years later oh my
goodness it's the best everyone should
do that
like just let him get really obsessed
how did you guys meet we met when we
were 12 oh my god I think you told me
this when we did your podcast here's
when I was equally shocked my dad caught
us in the closet at 12 do you guys go to
school together we went to school
together and we broke up for years and
years and got back together 21 so you're
like middle school sweetheart middle
school sweethearts that's so sweet so
how long have you guys been married now
we've been married for two years how's
married life it's good it's the same
that's what everyone says yes you're
getting you're engaged I'm engaged your
rings beautiful you okay tell me about
that like just a little tangent um he
has no we got engaged in February and
it's it's great being engaged is
wonderful and I always felt like being
engaged was like the best time of your
life and it definitely is but now I'm
really looking forward to like being
married because planning a wedding
take your time being engaged is fun the
planning a wedding is not know what are
you wondering I know that people in the
comments want me to ask you any tips for
planning a wedding because I need all
the help I can get I didn't plan one
thing till a month before I got married
really yeah I just didn't want the
pressure I was you know I'm building my
business and so I decided that I would
procrastinate like I do with everything
and I waited till the last minute and I
really didn't look at what anyone else
did I just did what I wanted where did
you get married
Cabo one & only Palmilla was it a big
wedding 50 people oh that's so silly I
blocked out the night before my wedding
there was drama I was working over oh
that's my nightmare like coz you have to
have like your rehearsal dinner or like
a dinner before the wedding
and if I'm hungover on my wedding day
like I get monster hangover there was
nothing helping you know sheet masks in
the world I was it was like so bloated
not great what I made my parents reshoot
the wedding photos that's how bloated oh
that's me I made everyone get dressed up
and reshoot the wedding photos do you
have any hangover remedies that like you
swear by a sheet mask a steam shower
lots of facial manipulation like really
people would think I'm crazy like
smacking my face like facial massager I
just I have a hack for a vibrator eight
dollar vibrator on Amazon around the
eyes you got to get the lymphatic system
going to flush it out okay so you know
all about the lymphatic system and like
all of these things that's just like
most people don't like where did you
learn all of this I'm gonna name my
firstborn lymphatic I'm not kidding I
love the lymphatics it's wonderful
emphatic system for those of us who
don't know okay so basically you want
your lymphatic system to be circulating
because if it's not an it's stagnant you
get puffy that's why you can get puffy
in your neck and you don't want to be
puffy you want
okay so to drain it you want to
manipulate massage your face and that
makes you go pee and that's the water
getting out of your body I learned about
this because my friend went to Shanghai
and he said that everyone was walking
around hitting themselves to work out
and that's because they get their
lymphatic system going so Tony Robbins
jumps on a trampoline in the morning
that gets it going a lot of people will
jump into freezing cold pool water just
like to really kickstart it oh my
goodness I need to get my lymphatic
system is dormant you guys I've never
done any of those things I wish I had a
trampoline but so what can like I
someone in the city was like no backyard
what can I do to get my lymphatic system
you can use your hands and just say just
go out and down make sure you go down
though because you don't want it to get
stuck in your face out and down and then
with the eyes you go under and down this
way so the opposite way okay and but get
an $8 vibrator off Amazon and just use
that on your face I need you do that
every day every day I cannot put makeup
on without it what do you do every like
what is your getting ready process like
before you do your makeup a lot of skin
I'm obsessed with skin your skin is
amazing thank you I would say you know
what it's not amazing right now in the
city the city wrecks habit because of
the pollution really yeah you guys just
I got a move I have to the city is
amazing you just isn't good for your
skin okay that's fair also there's no
good light we were just talking about
yeah we want to walk around with this
light around us 24/7 we do hard to take
a good it's hard to make a good photo in
the city like the sidewalks are so so
much trash that is not good for the
aesthetic it's not good there's a lot of
green and brown in there you know I just
found out that Lauren will not take a
picture in brown like if there's brown
in the photo she won't take the photo
which is so so crazy to me and so smart
cuz it really affects your flow it
totally affects your flow so for me I
just don't like the color brown like
like I don't like a brown couch like I
don't want it in there and I don't like
the color orange and I don't like the
color green in my feed okay I like pink
white and black in my feet your feet is
very unified some people will have a
brand that's brown and orange and green
and love it yes so you
it's not that it's not like I'm grossed
out with the color I just doesn't fit
the brand I know I understand yes I
think you would actually like my
apartment I think it's very on brand for
you what color is it
it's like white walls are white walls
and then like silver gray couch marble a
lot of like lucite silver love loose I
love lucite lucite is great for photos
yes yeah so stand in front of a white
wall with your lucite okay no I have so
many little pop of green for you see you
need greens
yeah P it became different colors that
will work for me pink green red yeah
white yes black and a little black I
can't help it I'm from New York like I
have to have black I love blocking my
feet yeah help a block is great okay you
guys things are gonna change for me
forever
yep I'm gonna be watching I'm gonna go
spending spark no the pressures on and
also I was telling me Freddie had this
conversation I was telling Lauren when
we did your podcast I was asking you how
you edit your photos and you told me
about this app called darkroom that
changed my life
and I haven't seen you since and so I
told you today that you really have
really helped me for those of you who
have never heard of darkroom like you
must get it it's kind of hard to figure
out at first
cuz you were saying that you can remove
certain colors or like change them and
it took me a while to like figure out
what worked for me but now you do it
quite calm now I do it quick and it's
everything and like you take pictures
that are in bad light and you can make
them look like they were taken in good
light yes so you can take whatever
colors you don't want in your Instagram
feed out of it I feel like I need to do
like a whole Instagram live on all these
linked really really do because I feel
like for you it's just like so simple
and elemental but for other people it's
like oh no I just use Instagram filters
and it's a and it's actually fun and
therapeutic to sit and edit your photos
yes unless you're well for me I take my
pictures while and like out and then I
post them on out so like I have ten
minutes where I'm just not talking to
anyone on my phone like trying to
optimize just go to the bathroom and
pretend like you're sick I've done that
a couple times okay yeah yeah all the
tips so what other apps like do you
swear by what's the new darkroom for me
so face tunes amazing for whitening the
background I do that okay you can whiten
your eyes a little bit you don't want to
go crazy you don't wanna look like a
cartoon character right but I love to
whiten the backgrounds of face - and I
love darkroom
I love after light with this go
obviously
visco it's so like overwhelming to me
let's go it's so easy okay
golly yeah yeah and then like do you
have one disco filter that like you
pretty much use for all of you right now
I'm loving green it's kind of like a Kim
K green okay
they have that in visco I'm gonna
transfer you to bisque oh okay you're
gonna be using this you tell me the use
disco I will use disco because you've
really changed my life so far and I have
so many life changes to make and I'm so
excited you're gonna be fameless I've
got Monday my little static system is
with me in check you guys won't
recognize me it's gonna be fantastic
okay second story kind of sad news Sam
Smith is going through some [ __ ]
following his breakup so very sad the
Grammy winner brought hits the thrill of
it all toward a Barclays Center on
Wednesday night and told the audience
he's going through a tough time I didn't
know he was in the city I don't know
much about Sam Smith I don't know that
much either but I feel like when someone
like there was a concert in the city
like it's all over my feet and I didn't
even know he was here
I didn't know he was here either maybe
Lauren into him maybe we'll get him
facial massaging definitely quote I know
that everyone in this room right now is
going through some [ __ ] I know I'm going
through some [ __ ] tonight I want all of
us just leave all of our worries and all
of our heartache aside and let's have
some fun so earlier that news earlier
that day news broke that him and the 13
reasons why actor Brandon Flynn had
split too much 13 reasons why I don't
but in this secret Facebook group
everyone raves about it oh oh my god
that's a whole other thing that we
haven't even talked about so you have a
secret Facebook group and you are one
two we have one two and it we both have
like equally wonderful community amazing
community and I just want to shout out
to all of those people who are our main
goal the communities like I just was
telling you earlier they're very similar
they're really nice cool girls yes and
we literally talked about the toasters
everything what is what are your fans
call themselves I just call them readers
but they call themselves skinnies that's
a cutie yeah it's really it's cheeky how
did you come up with the name the skinny
confidential so everyone asked me this
and they think it has to do with being
skinny it's just about getting the
skinny like getting the secret
oh just why I had to tell you about dark
room you know so is very own brand no I
thought it started as like a like a
health thing and then it kicked off into
like all the beauty and whatnot but
that's so I just think it's the skinny
get the skinny you definitely hit us
with the skinny so I'm quite
appreciative anyway so don't watch 13
reasons why and I don't really keep up
with Sam Smith but I'm really sad for
everyone who's really sad about their
breakup they seem like a really cute
couple
is he cute I don't I don't know what he
looks like I don't know heat there's not
a photo of him in this article but I'm
sure he's cute Sam Smith is yeah he's so
cute
remember when he was like that like he
lost so much weight yeah he's looking
good I'm a my friend Kristin wrote this
article hey Stan Congrats she's so cute
I love her um anyways Sam Smith is
looking good he definitely reads the
skinny have an intial I hope so Sam who
reads a skinny confidential that like
you found out and you're just like
obsessed with oh I don't know that's a
good question
um I don't have anyone I don't think
famous that's come up to me and told me
they read this can you confidentially no
I mean you thank you make a girl feel
special
no that's I feel like no you're
everywhere and your Instagram like your
community is like so dedicated it's just
like yours you have the same type of
community you know what else is great
it's like a both of them are very
non-judgmental community mm-hmm that's
really what I try to cultivate like we
don't want to talk about politics or
religion it's just like it's just a
place to get the skinny orgasms what you
know yeah everything and like meet
people that are like like-minded and
have the same interests that you
wouldn't have had a chance to meet
otherwise totally I've met so many girls
in there and they're there meeting each
other and doing meetups I'm sure that
you're the same and the meetups are so
cute they're so creative and also like
they just go to the cutest places they
have like the cutest steak or there's
this meetup that they do in the OC the
OC toasters and it's at like this
beautiful house on like the waterfront
but then I guess the girl whose house it
is her boyfriend like takes a boat and
goes across the channel and takes a
picture of them from the bow when I find
a boyfriend like right isn't that so
cute Wow I got a goal we need to go to
the next Osito store meetup because it
looks lit and I'm sure they do it very
on brand so it's fitting with the flow
yes yeah they really float as well like
died so okay this next way I feel like
is perfect for you because the
kardashian-jenner clan fire and unfollow
a long time makeup artist Joy's finale
okay I saw this this morning on the
Daily Mail that's where I'm reading it
from so do you follow Joyce
I don't follow Joyce we ran into her
when we were in the South of France and
I was like stalking her with my
binoculars she she was great she was
with her kid in her bikini drinking
Rosie she was at a club 55 and I was
just Michael was trying to talk to her I
need him a couple times to like say hi
or buy her a drink but I went and
checked and I can confirm that Khloe
Kardashian does not follow her anymore
that's so crazy but what's weird is that
I've realized this a few months ago and
I'm Connie and I talked about it and
like speculated and moved on and so I
don't understand why it's in the news
now how long ago did you know this how
did you find this information um I think
we were real either the toasters pointed
it out or we were just realizing that
Joyce like wasn't around and then we
looked to see if they still followed so
the toasters are like really good
investigators they are there they're the
CIA the toasters intelligence agency Wow
they have a group called the tea is wait
yeah you were they like sleuth hardcore
I need to be in that group
no it's wild they are literally like
boxing the kids at Quantico wow it's
incredible love it yeah
if you ever like have a mystery like I
don't know a social media mystery that
you need solved the TI is here can they
do like a cheating boyfriend situation
yeah oh they do a ton of cheating
boyfriend work okay it's really good
anyway so I'm sure was the toasters who
flagged it for us so now what's weird to
me about the stories why it's like in
the news now considering this has been
news for a while and then I'm reading
the like bullet points from the Daily
Mail and they seem very joy like
pro-choice so it makes me feel like she
kind of like their necessity enough
either the bullets are not giving us
what happened how did you notice no
exactly there's just like stating the
facts in the last ball it says in 2015
came copied Joyce's platinum blonde
locks like that feels like Joyce wrote
that but and that's like not enough like
that's not why they're like in a fight I
know and like I
feel like it takes so much for the
Kardashians to really cut someone out
like because once you're in their inner
circle like you're in and they'll give
you like they'll treat you like family
and family you got a lot of chances to
like for you to ostracize someone that
you consider family it has to be really
bad like remember when they fired Monica
Rose yeah that was that was big that was
like crazy I still want to know what
happened exactly
I so what I heard and what came out is
basically but she was kind of like
double dipping she was like charging
them for clothes that she was getting
for free how can you do that I don't
know when you're being promoted like
that I don't know I don't even
understand that it's and she was like
I'm her for her charging like her fee
which was crazy and like wasn't they
didn't realize what they were paying for
oh and then like Chris was going through
the books and then christening like an
email to a bunch of people like telling
them what she and what I like really
loved about the Kardashians is when they
cut you out it's all at once so they go
snip know totally like go cut throat
it's so cutthroat but that's what's so
amazing about them like as a family is
that they really have each other's backs
in that sense like no one is gonna turn
on the other totally like you [ __ ] with
one's to show you [ __ ] with you know
hair on a group text
oh my all together talking about Joyce
right now totally and the toasters get
the group text information yet that
would be next level but honestly I would
not be surprised
truly yeah the group the group Texas for
sure saying time to uncalled really love
to see their group texts I mean can you
imagine now I really could in can you
imagine like the conversation around
Kate like I can't even imagine there's
so much Tristan
oh did you see how she and they fall
yeah unblocked him yeah it made me happy
yeah cuz I just want happiness for Chloe
and yeah what Tristan did was [ __ ] up
but like it's about what's gonna make
Chloe happy for me yes and I think that
like they have an underlying
understanding between each other
Tristan and Chloe I think most celebrity
relationships do and that they have to
because it's so different like you know
yeah
it's you're in a whole nother if they
have it they have an understanding I
just feel bad for her that she was
pregnant
yes and that like everyone knows you
know guys now not only did you have to
go through but now she has to constantly
like defend herself yeah in a
relationship I'm like that's exhausting
totally exhausting but I like how the
Kardashians are accepting him back me
too like so maybe they are about second
chances
I don't think with Joyce I think I think
she's out
Monica enjoyed throughout that's so
scary honestly Ken like the girls style
has suffered since Monica left mostly
Kendall cuz Kendall is the only one who
really uses a stylist it has suffered a
bit and it's I've Kendall and Gigi were
both using her and they that was like
they looked amazing like she really
interact wonderful stylist and
afterwards it was like it took a while
for them to get back on track and now
it's fine but it's never like how it was
I feel like you should DM Monica and see
if she can like come like next time in
here we can do like she can come dress
us oh my god I would love that but we
don't want to have you stylist I have
never used a stylist me neither
I can't even imagine like what actually
I've been having trouble shopping
recently like I can't find anything I
feel like that election I like
efficiency and it saves you time so I
don't know what stylist yeah if you have
a stylist and they know what's gonna be
flattering or if you're gonna be on
camera or whatever you're gonna do they
know how to dress your body type and
they know like what's out there yes like
I have to go to every store to see
what's out there so it's a little
annoying maybe I need a stylist that
would be so extra though I like extra
though really yeah they need to make an
uber for a stylist that's like
affordable for all like glam squad
yeah stylist that's a really good idea
yeah that's very I'm read for you should
think about it I'll be a client okay
speaking of the Kardashians next up
Kylie Jenner Kanye West and Rihanna are
among times 25 most influential people
on the internet I mean that all makes
sense except the list is obviously
lacking because we're not on it but it's
fine
other people included our Busy Philipps
youtubers logan paul and jake paul the k
pop sensation BTS Donald Trump and the
Parkland shooting student activist so
very well-rounded list very well-rounded
I'm glad to say BTS is on it because
they are so influential did you watch
that award show where people were
literally screaming at the top like
there's a level of scream just like of
audience cheer there's a level of like
Shawn Mendes there's a level of Justin
Bieber and then there's a level of BTS
that I've never heard before higher than
Jake Paul I believe so okay it's so
crazy but you know who's a sleeper cell
on that list Busy Philipps she is a
sleeper cell I watch out for her she is
gonna be famous she's doing her thing
she has
show coming on e like a talk show and
cloudy and I have mixed feelings about
it because she's like famous for her
Instagram stories I guess
I don't follow her why follow her
sometimes and I think she's really good
really yeah she's cultivated an amazing
community she's real she's raw
I think her show is gonna be good I hope
it's good and also even if I like what
however I feel about her it is very cool
that like as a traditional actress she's
made the most of the digital community
so and that she understands the whole
realm
she's really evolved which is really
awesome to see a celebrity do she's
embraced the influencer and celebrity
side that I can appreciate hopefully
she'll have like all the Dawson's Creek
cast members on and she can be like a
reunion you know who I love Pacey
james Van Der Beek and I don't need a
much duck I never watched Dawson's Creek
yeah do you ever watch don't trust the B
in apartment 23 no what are these shows
that you're telling me that it was like
a two season show and it was cancelled
before its time and it's it's
heartbreaking
I probably rewatch it once a year I'm
Alex james van der beek plays himself
it's so good it's with like Krysten
Ritter and it's the most underrated show
okay toasters you need to watch it I
don't know if I've ever told you that
but you must you'll love it it's right
up there with Riverdale dynasty and the
kissing booth Wow
yeah do you have to ever now no but I
know you're a huge fan I am but I need
to watch more TV when I what do you
watch i watch Real Housewives a fan
course i watch the latest southern charm
but nothing before southern choices okay
then and I watched Vanderpump rules and
that's really what I watch too and then
I just like I'm binge watching Mad Men
right now okay I've watched Mad Men love
that show it's everything bad like I've
watched all those TV shows I'm into
billions okay I've only seen season one
of billions because I don't know how to
watch the rest of it now I don't know
how to get Showtime on demand but I
loved the first season's is amazing so
just relax
yeah he's insane he's insane it's so so
good I didn't need to catch up now yeah
billions or you have to add that to your
list so as someone who's just want only
watch this season of southern charm so
you don't like know a lot of the
backstory but who do you like I love
Cameron
I mean how can you yes she ain't show
barely on it this season and like she's
still a fan favorite she's I love her um
I like Shep I don't mind him I
understand him I understand him too and
he's hilarious yeah I'm like very smart
and knows who he is and yeah even though
I like him even if it's not what you
would want for him like he's happy
that's why I like him he knows who he is
he knows what he is and he's a cool
thing he's unapologetically doing
himself
mm-hmm I also like oh I know who I like
Patricia oh you do I just finished her
book have you read it no what's it
called the art of southern harm okay
what is it about amazing I finished it
in a weekend it tells you everything you
need to do like in life so she has her
dressing room that she gets dressed in
with her martini and her Butler and she
talks all about how you can do your own
and how to throw a party and where to
put a napkin and how to be a lady and
how to get a guy gotta watch God gotta
read it everyone needs to read about
honestly I will read that book I haven't
like I wasn't always a fan of hers
because I felt like she was really hard
on Kathryn but this season I feel like
she's coming like she's coming around
and I like her more and I feel I love
the idea of her you know like this just
glamorous woman she's a muumuu always in
the movie like she's lived she has
wisdom for days but I just felt like she
was a little too mean for me but this
season I'm seeing a different side of
her I'll say I think if you read her
book you'll see a different side - I
agree because I want to know more about
her story like what got her to be like
so glamorous I mean she's had three
husbands that's crazy she walks you
through it all she walks you how to get
a guy she walks you how a lady should
act she I mean she's so good oh my god
I'm well I will actually read it that's
action a book I would like don't finish
it what do you know when she wrote it
she wrote it probably I think a year ago
oh okay so since she's been yeah a
reality I really want to interview her
in her dressing room and like go to
Charleston and sit down with her have
you been shot Amy I reached out so
Patricia if you're watching yeah she
actually I don't know if she's watching
right now but she gets around on the
internet like she sees what's out there
and being sad about the show so there is
a chance
this could cross her desk okay I think
you should do it and then I would watch
hey listen I'm gonna read your book okay
next story fifth and final story before
we just get into all things TSE um lying
ryan lochte faces six months in prison
as brazilian court rules he will be
prosecuted for falsely claiming he was
robbed at gunpoint after drunken
interview during the Rio Olympics how
crazy is that what the superior tribunal
dead Jessica oh my god we are the
superior supriya real tribunal dead Jew
Sica because we serve up justice on the
show all day if there's anyone you feel
like serving coasters for it let me know
we can make it happen
rolled on Wednesday that prosecutors can
move forward with criminal charges
against Ryan Lochte the swimmer is
facing one to six months prison and a
possible fine for lying to members of
the delegation speciale yet attend
Demento io turista Wow he was questioned
by the group after falsely telling Billy
Bush he had been robbed at gunpoint
during a drunken interview at the Rio
Olympics Lochte had previously rejected
a deal that would have dismissed any
further charges if he had paid a seventy
thousand dollar fine I'm sure he's
regretting that now that's so crazy I
thought that this was over and he just
had a baby oh my goodness I can't
believe that one that this has followed
him for so long and and then they didn't
settle it and that is such like what he
said was really [ __ ] up and stupid and
weird but that it was like such a big
deal legally the internet never forgets
no you know not I mean hopefully
honestly I almost forgot until I saw
this I mean he probably really will have
to do jail time huh and like in Brazil
rough and I feel like either on the one
hand it's like no he won't he's Ryan
Lochte like he'll get out of it's on the
other hand they'd like to make a an
example of celebrities you know yes
exactly feel like this could be a
situation like that a parasail moon jail
thing
yeah yeah or Chloe in jail Lindsay Lohan
Wow oh my goodness that is so wild I I
did forget about it maybe just community
service maybe that would be nice and I
feel like that punishment would fit the
crime yeah
community service he needs to start
reconsidering he insulted them yeah very
fair okay now we are going to just talk
about all things
yes because when we did your podcast I
remember we were talking about Botox and
I was and for months I've been saying
how badly I wanted it I finally got it
two weeks ago
it looks amazing where'd you get it I
got it dr. Sharon Jeezy on the Upper
East Side okay and but like wearing
those I got this line I really only went
in for this sign because I would always
fur on my brows and would leave a
wrinkle and I didn't want to be able to
make that face anymore so I got it there
and then she just like did a couple
units up here it looks really good and
my favorite part I didn't even ask for
this but she didn't do these so I can
still raise my eyebrow perfect do you
want a little raise and I love the art
of raising an eyebrow yeah you I love
the art of raising an eyebrow keep the
eyebrow so you can raise it yeah like
even if it gets like so wrinkled I won't
stop so how often do you recommend
getting Botox this thing is everyone's
different like you you really have to go
to a good doctor don't do a Groupon
don't do a Groupon for Botox okay go to
a good doctor and ask them what they
think and come in with your own agenda I
started when I was 21 years old and I
just got my number 11 done and I feel
like it just opens up right here and now
I get my forehead done too and I love it
I love it I feel like I have a new far
headed so I never have you been loved
and talked about how I felt about my far
head and now I'm just like look at my
car you're thrilled was so proud yeah it
looks really it's a good forehead thank
you and now I just want like the rest of
my I wanna be as proud as of the rest of
my face but you don't want it around
your mouth because then you can't smile
no exactly and I am very my mouth is
moves in a million different ways and I
like that especially for the show yeah
you can't for the show yeah I don't want
to be sitting like this no no no we need
the bottom part to move so what other
skin care dermatology cosmetology things
do you do so I talked about getting my
boobs done on the skinny confidential I
don't know if that's good night and I
think I have to get them redone next
month when did you do them I didn't when
I was 19 and why do you like it's just
me it's time to get them redone and if I
get them redone I'm gonna be like
filming the whole thing not like in
surgery but you know I'm gonna like rock
the legs I really appreciate like I
understand people who are private about
this sort of stuff and good for you but
I really appreciate people who are
public about
because so many people have these
thoughts or questions about it and no
one you need good information totally my
photographer who's here right now
Arielle
she just got her nose done and she
opened up about it on social media and
the outline of support has been amazing
people want to start talking about
things like this I think that that more
influencers should you know own ah well
speaking of the southern charm Naomi got
no job okay she looks amazing it's
beautiful we wait on this season that
I'm watching she doesn't know she got it
so packed her this season so she was on
watch what happens live and in a few of
her interviews that are filmed
afterwards she has a new different nose
okay so and it looks so good and she
talked about on watch I was live and
like I feel like people try to deny this
stuff all the time and it's like we can
tell so not only did you do this you're
also a liar and she's but she looks
amazing on the season I'm watching she's
so beautiful like but I guess like her
nose like she said she's one-on-one
since she was eight and I like go out
there and get one go out there and get
one yeah do you you know yeah I think
that my biggest problem is
hyperpigmentation so I have like a brown
son mustache and like brown spots on my
face
so I'm a huge advocate of not going in
the Sun because yes I've seen all of
your the links that you go to it's so
many links the links I go to I mean Sun
hot driving gloves like driving driving
gloves you can get them off Amazonas
knee I need driving those because I've
gotten like freckles on my hands and
like that's just a weird place that's so
important I mean you can't forget about
your neck and your shoulders cuz that's
what shows the truth I'm gonna do a blog
post called
it called like the neck shows the truth
that's really you know just think about
I always bring it down to even like your
nipples yes when you're doing your like
Kate Somerville moisturizer you just
like bring it down to your nipples okay
that's that's very true cuz you show so
much decolletage totally and it's more
lymphatic interesting yeah so do you
spray tan because you don't stay in the
Sun I spray tan do you want to know how
obnoxious I am yes so today I was
feeling pale and you know I didn't have
time to go to a spray tan booth so I had
a mobile situation come to my hotel and
this morning this morning they just
sprayed me Oh
took five minutes listen good I need I
need sex I went to make an appointment
yesterday cuz I figured you would have a
spray tan I didn't
eggs on the show and they're just so
pale so as I'll get it like you pale
though I have to tell you you it's very
useful thank you sometimes in the summer
I like to look tan and also I'm like I'm
going to a country concert tonight I'm
so excited you guys by the way some
toasters are gonna be there and I'm
literally to this concert for weeks it's
weird like what's the concert it's dan +
Shay Rascal Flatts
okay do you like country nothing about
country oh my god it's not only I love
the music but also just the vibes are so
good like I'm I don't would say why the
energy would be amazing and the venue
that it's at it's like out New Jersey
people are gonna be tailgating all day
and I'm like I need to leave this
concert uh since our till 7:30 but I
want to leave the city at like 4:00 and
just be there okay so what time will you
be up till tonight
oh I don't probably at least midnight
midnight so you're not like too late
you're not like some New Yorkers are
five in the morning oh yeah I'm not time
in the morning like I'm past that now
ever since I've turned 25 I've just come
to terms with this next chapter in my
life of drinking less and partying less
and I'm very happy with and you're
engaged so you want to play that you
have to like playing yeah I'm in your
life yeah you just have to like grow up
when you grow up and it's really nice
like having a glass of wine and it's
very nice little cheese and maybe some
Cornish UNS watching The Bachelor s
Commission's little pickles they're
great with cheese
I need carnations he loves pickles I eat
too many pickles and those blew me too
okay you've got to get the little ones
everything's floating here the pasta the
pizza the weather do you take any like
I've been starting to take these like
humm vitamins have you heard of it I
love home vitamin okay so I have the
skinny one and flatter me so the skinny
Bernie yes it's good and I have to be
honest like I've been taking them for a
month or two not consistently I probably
forget some days and I take them when I
see them but like I've never felt that
her so I don't think they're working for
me you look great I have to tell you you
look great your skin looks great you're
glowing your forehead I mean I used to
people there's a real contribution she's
running for head verse far head I say
far head what's far head I saved my far
head oh like my forehead I know and wait
what do you say sir head for head like
it's like orange orange water with our
head I don't know yeah I'm talking about
like Teresa Giudice or something
different for heads it's my accent I say
far head okay and people
our shook by it and I've never liked I I
always see in the comments and I saw
people were laughing that we were saying
it differently and they always forget to
address it but you guys think that's
just how I talk or do you say forehead
or 4head anyone chooses 4head 4head
4head 4head they're out of towners far
ahead I mean it's just it's a tomato
Tomatoes you know what though I like
pronouncing stuff wrong every once in a
while yeah it's like my only where you
just haven't show all the eyes can't
chant yeah it's my favorite there's just
sometimes a little mispronouncing it's
like it's brands you I agree it's a good
brand I totally agree okay now I'm gonna
go to the Instagram because we have so
many questions for you and I would be
remiss if I didn't ask you them if
there's any ones about the flow oh my
god if there's I will I'd ask you what
apps you use to edit your photos I feel
like we're all in a really good place
about to have everyone feel like we're
feeling good with the Instagram feed I'm
feeling good about it okay you need a
good bio
I mean obvious things like that you want
your highlights to be a cute yes
especially if you're a blogger yes you
know like you want like good highlight
covers you know what I'm talking about
yes oh yeah I I don't have those and
also in green pink and green like in
green I I'm a blogger with no blog I
like don't what it means to like the
writer job like you're out with no blog
like the way that I use Instagram you
would think I have a blog but I don't
that's okay though yeah it's kind of
like a micro blog yes I am a micro
bugger you guys yeah I'm into that okay
so more questions about being an
influencer advice on how to find your
niche as an influencer and if you think
it's worth trying to be an influencer
today in an already saturated space I do
not think this space is saturated and if
I hear one more person say that every
other blow my head off this space is not
saturated it just started that's like
saying the restaurant industry is
saturated I mean it's a there's room for
everyone I think that that's an excuse
that people are telling themselves as to
not to get started I think you should
stop thinking about that it is so many
open spaces there's so much room to
shine we're dealing with the world you
know you're not dealing with two gas
stations that are next to each other
you're dealing with everyone so for your
niche I would find one thing and I would
talk about it for two years every single
day so I started with health and fitness
and I always say it's like an upside
down
triangle so you start with your niche
and then you slowly grow out and expand
and talk about other things I didn't
introduce my husband to the blog for two
years I was super methodical and
strategic about how I was was going to
kind of introduce the characters in my
life so I think it's kind of like when
when you're dating someone you don't
want to give it all up
at first you want to kind of dangle the
key and like and make them like you kind
of charm them a little bit that's how
you want to be with a blogger you want
you wanted to get real niche in specific
make them wait for it and slowly grow
out okay
that's so interesting am i overwhelming
you know you're not with it flow and the
highlights and this no no the highlights
I'm all on highlights my highlights are
actually very like category like very
organized okay we try we try it I'm all
about organization and slow and that
flow I'm I'm all up on flow but known it
like this being you and Claude this is
this is your total is it niche or niche
another thing I sometimes say Misha and
sometimes it depends I'm feeling I'm
gonna say niche I don't know what the
correct one is yeah uh you guys found
your niche this is your niche you guys
have really rodent you've done an
amazing job and now you can like expand
out into whatever you know clods
obviously traveling and I think that's
the way to do it instead of trying to do
everything at once I mean a lifestyle
blogger yes what is your current
skincare routine it changes so much
because I'm constantly trying products
but I'll tell you my ride-or-die
products are dr. Dennis gross vitamin C
okay love it is that is that a lotion
it's it's kind of like a serum it's a
light consistency and then I love Kate
Somerville it's like a super thick
oxygenating moisturizer I like the derma
quench - I love oil I cannot live
without oil you got to have a good oil
oil oil like rose hip oil avocado what
about Mary Cujo whale I had that great
okay and like I'm traveling right now
and I don't have an oil so I called down
for room service and said can I get an
extra virgin olive oil and took my
makeup off so is that what you used to
take your makeup off always because it's
super delicate even I make it I put it
on the cotton ball I put it on my hands
and just oil cleanse my face and then
after I'm cleanse my face I put more oil
on I look really hot before I go to bed
you could imagine oh my god that's so
funny yeah it's a lot of oil oils are
everywhere I'm all about weight like
dewy skin
and I just brought you coconut oil lube
like there's like it's all kinds of
there's a lot of oils going on got it so
do you all like your whole-- I try to
Idol everywhere
I think oil is the key to youth with
skincare because it just seeps in your
skin and gives you this really
moisturize skin got it and so what do
you use it on your hair ever or I don't
use it on my hair too much you can do a
hair mask with coconut oil and I should
mention don't put coconut oil on your
face cause it clogs your pores oh don't
do coconut body only so what do you do
for your hair my hair I'm pretty low
maintenance I wash it once a week and I
I mean I try to either get a blowout if
I don't get a blowout or wash it at home
I just did like a hair challenge where I
washed it with one one thing for one
month and I feel like it grew but the
this is extensions how much of it is
extension not it's my hair is probably
here it's not really for sickness it's
more for length right now oh well they
look great thank you they're clipping
I'm growing my hair out I feel like I'm
always saying that your hair is looking
really cute thank you it's so [ __ ]
sick Oh thick cuz I've been doing
collagen peptides okay just with
shampoos I've only used it once to mane
and tail which is the horse Shemp
everyone loves that shampoo I used to
back in high school and like my hair was
long and now that I'm trying to grow it
out again cuz I think I don't want short
hair for my wedding so are you gonna do
an extension moment for your wedding I
might I had clip-in extensions for a few
years I don't like custom-made for my
hair cuz like my hair is like very
unique and I can't find them is this
your real hair color hmm wow really
mm-hmm you're lucky when I was
describing you to my family I was like
telling them all about your hair it's
like amazing the perfect shade it's good
for the flow it's great that's so that's
something I have a barrette I love a
Papa rod Thanks okay what is your
recommendation for a cheaper version of
the Clarisonic facial massager a
vibrator like an actual vibrator okay
like you Google sexual vibrator on
Amazon and $8 okay use it on your face I
mean get to cuz you know if you're gonna
do other things that the other one I'm
good too you know I need you do it every
day before your makeup I have a
Clarisonic but I also have been using
the vibrate
just to test it out and I have to do
either one of those everyday I cannot
not do it for how long five minutes if I
can I mean once you start feeling the
lymphatic drainage because it's kind of
gross how do you go okay in the back of
your throat okay like it drains what
exit didn't fluid I know you can feel it
but like if you're doing it I couldn't
feel it you'll be able to definitely
feel a difference your face will be
contoured and just a side note Kim K
gets it done before all of that facial
massage okay to contour I need that I'm
gonna do that today actually except my
face is looking round please explain how
did you and everyday facial massage
without equipment just with your hands
just go out and down the neck just make
sure you go down the neck okay and your
top tip for under eye bags lymphatic
drainage I know I keep saying this but
people think that the reason their eyes
are puffy is because they're
sleep-deprived it's actually fluid that
needs to be drained so I would what I
would do is I would get like an eye mask
on both eyes obviously and I like the
sturm ones there's this one by this
brand that I've been using it's ER zo or
no there's no laws or no last yeah yeah
I use those to the under I think they're
great they're so good there's like
they're sura me huh leave them on until
they dry out yes okay I leave mine on
for four years like yeah the longer the
better with that you know yeah oh my god
that's so funny I randomly got them and
I now I'm obsessed with them that's
nobody that you just right there a pink
thing huh metallic and I can't pronounce
the name good for the photonic am and
I'm saying either it's like or no laughs
laughs yeah it's a hard brand of for now
yeah so you put those on and do your
facial massage inward and down with them
on and it's next level I'm doing that
right after this it's next level most
you can chill your iPad's that's a good
tip for inflammation okay in the
refrigerator okay yeah a nice roller is
great for insemination
Jade roller just you're rolling you want
to get the fluid out okay that is so
what face masks to use I love sheet
masks on the plane I love to look at you
like you're so crazy I don't care I
really don't care
I you should see the [ __ ] I do in public
I do i when I'm blogging you know how
like fashion blogger is like going like
they do different outfits I literally
will change on the street
oh my god so Arielle and I just got like
a spray tan cover do you know what I'm
talking about like um like a mobile
spray like a tent a tent yeah and I'm
gonna use that now on the street oh my
god that's amazing we and I need to know
where you got your spray tan this
morning I know what are you guys I will
leave the info on my Instagram story
I didn't look it so I don't have like
the name but I will leave it on my
Instagram story okay and I'm her info
what are your three favorite beauty
products that you take with you on every
trip this is redundant but facial
massage are tons of sunscreen and I like
a caffeinated sunscreen because it
tightens your face and then I have like
this forever 21 pink makeup case with my
makeup in it and in it is like better
than sex mascara a shoe or mono curling
iron can not live with that not curling
iron not eyelash eyelash curler Wow your
eyelashes are amazing perfect there are
dull one-thirteenth individual there's a
lot of like hair situations happening
here like it doesn't look fake which is
so okay good that's how I want to set
your eyelashes there are dull 1:13 you
guys go to the drugstore and get them
they're so cheap and they're so good are
they the individual ones or the shrimp
no they're the strip agree you ain't got
to put mascara on after it they're on
that's why they probably look individual
got it and do you do fake lashes
everyday no only when I'm shooting
content or doing something like this I
actually don't wear makeup probably four
times a week really until it's like it's
a lot it is you know don't you feel like
getting ready a lot it is I have to do
the I do my makeup every morning but
then if I'm not doing anything later
that day I just take it off immediately
when I get home like I love just sitting
with like and letting my skin breathe ID
same with me I'd rather just have like
tons of oil then tons of makeup yeah not
a big makeup person I'm works good but
these eyelashes are great
everyone needs them yeah I feel like
with good skin and just a lash you're
good to go yes how do you manage people
who think they're working hard and doing
a good job but aren't oh this is a hard
question I I did not go into this as an
entrepreneur I went into it as a
solopreneur
meaning I was working for myself setting
my own schedule doing my own discipline
and then when I started adding people to
my team it was something that was really
new for me
wasn't used to communicating I found
working with a team now that the most
powerful thing you can do is communicate
constantly and over communicate to the
point where you're like I'm being
obnoxious okay um that's worked best for
me it's just to really communicate and I
think everyone deserves a chance if
they're if they're not doing a good job
they should be communicated they're not
doing a good job and maybe give them
ways to improve I also always lead with
a positive so when I'm emailing people
like I'll never start with unfortunately
or negative words I always start with a
really positive positive reinforcement I
think it's really important when you're
running a business okay that's so nice
well congratulations on all of your
success congratulations on all yours -
I'm with you
anyone that has light like this 24/7 is
doing something right like what a fetter
no it's really - it's great for selfies
especially in this city I'm glad we
recognize how hard it is to eat pictures
honestly I have like so much compassion
for you I feel so bad for you it's hard
to take a picture it really is
but with dark room it's better and now
with disco you guys we have homework to
do this weekend my at like literally I'm
gonna be going to this concert with like
my lymphatic system cleansed my eyes
drains yeah your forehead mics are new
for my new Tsar head on fleek and it's
gonna be amazing and then the pictures
I'm gonna take her is just gonna put me
over the top
yeah you guys I mean no one has be
getting something really exciting for me
no one I saw happen
it's all happening thank you so much for
tuning in we'll be back on Monday with
Claudia you can follow Lauren at the
skinny confidential enjoy thank you guys
love you have a great weekend bye guys
you